es ist endlich soweit wir können tomaten
ford sehen und wie das funktioniert das
zeige ich dir heute so dass du am ende
richtig schön kräftige gedrungene
pflanzen heißt nicht so schwächliche
langgezogene dinge sondern genauso tolle
tomatenpflanzen vor ziehst wie man sie
aus der gärtnerei kennt und der erste
schritt ist natürlich dass ihr euch erst
mal überlegt welche sorten ihr überhaupt
anbauen wollt und euch das saatgut
besorgt ich habe mal ein video über die
fünf tomatensorten gemacht die wir am
liebsten an bauern bei sie lecker sind
weil sie ertragreich sind und gut
wachsen robust sind das kann ich euch
gerne mal unten in der video
beschreibung verlinken genauso wie meine
komplette tomatenanbau playlist so dass
ihr euch da durchklicken kennt aber ihr
könnt ja auch mal in die kommentare
schreiben mit welchen worten ihr die
besten erfahrungen gemacht habt weil da
glaube ich ganz viele leute gerne durch
schauen uns nicht ein bisschen
inspiration holen aber ich filme das
video hier vor das heißt ich sehe jetzt
nur eine sorte aus und auch nur in den
ganz kleinen maßstab um euch das einmal
zu demonstrieren und macht dann mit euch
mit sobald das video online ist und dann
geht es richtig los mit der anzucht das
allerwichtigste was man am anfang
erstmal wissen muss ist dass tomaten nur
keinen wenn es richtig schön knackig
warm ist die wollen so ungefähr 20 bis
24 grad haben damit die überhaupt
aufgehen und keimen können das heißt
wenn wir unsere tomaten gleich sehen
dann stellen wir die in die nähe der
heizung auf die heizung ist ein bisschen
zu warm meistens und vor allem trocknen
die töpfchen dann super schnell aus das
wollen wir auch jeden pfennig aber ich
gehe sie oft unter die heizung natürlich
mit einem untersetzer oder sie ist schön
ordentlich warm also wärmer als normale
zimmertemperatur als anfang vom ende der
gekaufte anzuchterde verwenden ich
verwende da ganz gerne tor frei
der erde einfach weil ich das
ökologischer finde und sinnvoller und
man wirklich keinen kopf braucht um die
tomaten voll zu ziehen
du kannst aber auch gut ausgereift und
kompost nehmen solange der unkrautfrei
ist oder möglichst unkrautfrei so dass
nicht so viele andere pflanzen aufgehen
und wirklich schön reif also dunkel und
klein krümelig und schön nach waldboden
riecht dann kannst du tomaten auch in
kompost vorziehen das ist gar kein
problem viele leute denken immer dass
kompost viel schärfer wer und den
pflanzen irgendwie schadet als er
wirklich ist aber wir haben damit super
erfahrungen gemacht und bei uns wachsen
die tomaten die wir in kompost vorziehen
am allerbesten wenn du an sagt er du
verwendest du musst du später darüber
sprechen wir gleich auch noch ein
bisschen mehr düngen also ein bisschen
mehr dünger ins gießwasser geben
ansonsten ist das aber auch gar kein
problem dabei sehe ich ungefähr fünf
samen in einem töpfchen je nachdem wie
groß seine töpfe sind kannst du
natürlich auch 100 in eine große schale
seelen wenn du so viele tomaten anbauen
möchte ist einfach so dass jedes korn so
ungefähr 1 cm zu allen seiten platz hat
darauf versuche ich zu achten aber das
ist nicht ganz so wichtig die gehen also
erst mal alle zusammen in einem töpfchen
auf oder mehreren köpfchen und anbieten
wie die später also wie pflanzen die
später um das zeige ich euch gleich in
eigene töpfchen so dass jede pflanze
einen eigenen topf hat und wenn du die
tomaten aus setzt dann selbst du die
körner einen zentimeter tief dafür
kannst du die erde wieder ein bisschen
zur seite schieben in deinen anzucht
köpfchen diese ansehen und die dann
wieder mit einem zentimeter erde
bedecken und ein bisschen leicht
andrücken aber sollte schon noch schön
locker sein oben drauf und dann gehst du
das ganze vorsichtig an am besten mit
einer gießkanne die eso eine brause
vorne hat mir ganz feine so dass der
harte wasserstrahl nicht deine samen
wieder nach oben spült und alles
durcheinander bringt und dann hältst du
das bis sie aufgegangen sind auf jeden
fall schön schön feucht und stellt das
wie gesagt an einen warmen ort so dass
die pflanzen da richtig schön aufgehen
können und sobald sich die allerersten
pflänzchen zeigen und die pflanzen
aufgehen müssen die tomaten in einen
kühleren raum umziehen beziehungsweise
von der heiz und wegziehen in einen raum
wo es ungefähr 16 bis 18 grad ist weil
dann mit
wer ein bisschen kühler das gilt auch
für den allermeisten anderen gemüse
pflanzen die man jetzt vorziehen kann
also so ganz warm das kap nicht da wären
die pflanzen sehr dünn und schwächlich
und irgendwie nicht so toll wie wenn sie
kühler stehen also wirst du einfach nach
dem coolsten ort in dubai befindet und
da dein ernst doch regal hin und ich
empfehle euch ja immer die pflanzen
gerade so sachen wie tomaten nicht an
der fensterbank falls zu ziehen weil
jetzt gerade ist es draußen einfach noch
nicht hell genug und die meisten fenster
kriegen nicht genug licht so dass die
pflanzen alles bekommen was sie brauchen
wenn du nichts anderes hass und die
keine pflanzen lampen kaufen möchtest
ist das natürlich besser als gar nichts
dann such dir das nächste fenster dass
du hast aber gerade sind die tage auch
einfach noch zu kurz die pflänzchen die
wollen 16 stunden licht am tag und das
kriegen sie einfach auch am fenster
nicht und deswegen arbeiten wir mit led
pflanzen lampen die kann ich euch auch
mal wieder unten in die video
beschreibung packen wenn hier schauen
wird welche wir verwenden die strahlen
in komischen farben und das sieht immer
ein bisschen seltsam aus und alle leute
denken dass wir hanf anbauen können
aber die funktioniert nie richtig gut
und da kriegt man dann auch im haus so
richtig perfekte pflanzen hin wie man
die aus der gärtnerei kennt und eben
nicht diese langgezogenen gelblichen
schwächlichen pflanzen die wir zum
beispiel immer hatten wenn die an der
fensterbank vorgezogen haben aber das
liegt eben auch daran mich also wie groß
das fenster ist wie soll ich das fenster
ist und so weiter
jetzt haben wir also hier so einen
kindergarten von tomatenpflanzen jetzt
ist es weiter wichtig ist die erde
feucht bleibt und sobald sich die ersten
richtigen blätter zeigen also am anfang
bilden die tomatenpflanzen ja so ganz
schmale andere blätter die nicht so
tomaten artig aussehen das sind die kmu
blätter und danach kommen die ersten
richtigen blätter und das ist das
stadium wenn die ersten richtigen
blätter zum vorschein kommen wohin die
pflanzen am besten zitieren kann das
heißt wir wollen uns die pflanzen jetzt
aus dem topf ist ganz vorsichtig man
fast die immer besser an den blättern
als am stängel bei der stängel sehr
empfindlich und die blätter können das
besser ab und dann trennen wir die
pflanzen voneinander wenn die ganz lange
wurzeln haben kann man
einkürzen unten da werden die angeregt
noch mehr wurzeln zu bilden dann kriegt
man kräftige pflanzen und dann setzen
wir jedes einzelne tomaten pflänzchen in
einen einzelnen topf um ihr könnt
entweder einmal pikieren dann könnt ihr
die gleiche größere tapian um pflanzen
dann nehme ich ungefähr so breite so
hohe topf für das sie wirklich viel
platz zu haben bis sie groß und stark
werden können oder ihr pikiert sie
später noch mal und setzt sie jetzt
erstmal in einzelne kleine töpfchen
das ist nicht unbedingt nötig aber führt
manchmal dazu dass man noch ein bisschen
kräftigere pflanzen bekommt wenn man sie
dann später noch mal tiefer einsetzen
kann
beim parkieren kann man sie nämlich also
der stängel ist jetzt ziemlich lang und
den kann man schon in der erde
verbuddeln bis zu den blättern dass
gerade die blätter noch rausschauen so
dass die an dem ich denke noch mehr
wurzeln gehen und das kennt ihr sicher
wenn ihr schon mal tomaten angebaut habe
dass die auch unten am stängel wurzeln
bilden können und so stehen sie dann ein
bisschen kräftiger und ergeben kräftige
pflanzen dann drücken wir sie vorsichtig
an
gießen sie wieder vorsichtig an auch
wieder mit einer feinen brause und dann
kennen die wieder unter die pflanzen
lampe wandern die pflanzen dann habe ich
übrigens so eingestellt dass sie 16
stunden am tag leuchtet so dass sie mit
einer zeitschaltuhr einfach morgens
angeht weiß es noch bevor wir aufstehen
abends wenn wir ins bett gehen geht sie
irgendwann aus so dass wir nicht daran
denken müssen und die pflanzen trotzdem
alles bekommen was sie brauchen und dann
wird es langsam zeit dass die mal ein
bisschen was zu futtern bekommen gerade
wenn ihr nur anzuchterde verwendet habt
dann reichen die nährstoffe oft nicht so
lange aus und dann denke ich die ich
nehmen dafür wie nasse denn wenn ich
welche finde im internet kann ich euch
den auch unten in die video beschreibung
packen das ist meiner erfahrung nach der
dünger auf den tomaten am meisten ab
fahren natürlich ein biologischer dünger
den für den ich aber ungefähr doppelt so
stark wie es auf der packung angegeben
ist damit die jungen pflanzen es noch
nicht überfordert werden die haben doch
nicht so in nur um nährstoffbedarf aber
ein bisschen düngung brauchen sie eben
aber wenn du deine
nur in anzuchterde ausgesät hast du
nicht in kompost und gibt ihnen ruhig
noch ein kleines bisschen mehr dünger
mit ins gießwasser man gießt die
pflanzen immer so dass man das wasser in
die unterlage gehst und dann steigt das
gleichmäßig hoch in die tröpfchen so
kann sichergehen dass alle pflanzen
genauso viel wasser bekommen wie sie
brauchen und man nicht nur oberflächlich
die erde angefeuchtet hat wenn eine
pflanze langsam ins teenager alter
kommen also ungefähr so groß sind dann
kannst du auch mal weniger gießen so
dass er ein bisschen austrocknet
natürlich soll nämlich vertrocknete also
wir wollen jetzt die pflanzen hier auch
nicht foltern aber das führt eben dazu
dass sie ihre wurzeln besser ausbilden
dass sie ein bisschen selbstständiger
werden weil sie sich ein bisschen mehr
anstrengen müssen um meerwasser zu
bekommen ja und das führt dann eben dazu
dass man kräftigere und selbständige
pflanzen und dann ins bett aus pflanzen
kann ihr könnt die tomaten dann mitte
mai nach den eisheiligen also nach den
letzten posten nach draußen pflanzen
frost wollen die nicht unbedingt haben
und wie das funktioniert welche dünger
mischung wieder ins pflanzloch geben ist
und so weiter
darüber habe ich schon mal ein video
gemacht also schaut auf jeden fall mal
da drüben vorbei wenn das bei euch an
steht ansonsten sehen wir uns am samstag
wieder mit einem neuen video hier guckt
schon die erste raus